so so max in you might I call you Mario
from now on because you're if you're
Mario in the in the computer game ma so
III imagine Mario someone coming into a
Mario game and calculating how high he
jumps and how fast he runs and coming up
with the laws of physics of the game and
possibly then questioning why is it that
and not something else perhaps and so is
the fine but is there why would that
allow someone in the game to have any
understanding of what's outside the game
yeah that's a really deep and good
question
Mario might if Mario can never even if
he figures out exactly of the rules of
his world then he just exactly know if
he's running on a Mac or a Windows box
or a Linux box right cuz all these has
access to is this higher level of this
sort of emergent reality we might that
some level be stuck in that situation in
physics also it's it's quite fascinating
to think that so much of what we figured
out for example about how a glass of
water works with waves and war disease
and things we figured out already
without having a clue about the
substrate we didn't even know there were
atoms you know but the same kind of
questions that you're asking which I
think are awesome the kind of questions
where you ask suppose this is actually
somehow simulated suppose the simulator
is cutting corners
how would that show up actually has been
incredibly useful in the past you know
if you're trying to if you imagine going
back 200 years and trying to simulate
this water as an infinitely the
continuous liquid where there's a
pressure and a density that has to be
defined with instantly many decimal
places an interesting debate points that
sounds horrible to simulate so maybe
they maybe whoever did it cut corners
maybe there's a smallest kind of chunk
of object let's call it a thumb or
something you can figure out that what
are the kind of departures from this
simplified continuous physics that I'm
guilty of teaching my undergrads and MIT
about this
this morning and you would figure out
where there's this train down she's
different a few hours ago from bridge
ground thank you for coming in Brownian
motion that things should jiggle around
and I said a weird way and Einstein
found that you know got the Nobel Prize
for it partly and
I think that the sort of thing you're
doing is awesome look for corner-cutting
evidence
I suspect that where they were simulated
or not there are a lot of things that
are wrong about when we assume today I
am very skeptical that we really have a
continuous space that can be stretched
infinitely many times it seems like some
sort of simplification that we came up
because it was easier to do that with
because it was easier to do the mass the
case why do we need a discretized
universe I mean if if you put away the
simulation hypothesis or a computational
hypothesis why should we even think
about a discretize universe why not to
continue so this is this is an important
yeah I don't to call it a problem in
physics but a reality of physics that
our macroscopic world looks continuous
to us and that has a certain simplicity
of modeling and then as you get smaller
smaller smaller it's no longer
continuous and it's discrete which may
be easier to calculate then being able
to be divisible all the way down to an
infinitesimally small bit because now
you need that much bigger a computer to
do it by the way we have real question
whether space is discrete well we run
into this problem when we do flyovers in
the Hayden Planetarium we have a data
set for a planetary surface let's say
Mars and you're at a given distance and
from that distance you can see Olympus
Mons the biggest mountain around and in
Valles Marineris and you say fine now I
want to get closer well to get closer
and have more information come to you
you have to swap in a higher resolution
map and we try to do that continuously
so you don't realize that so you keep
doing this and then you reach a point
where we don't have more resolution to
give you so we actually hold you back so
you don't go closer but if you did all
of a sudden you see these discretize
pixels
of the Martian surface and that's
basically because we don't have the data
we're not there it doesn't exist for us
so anyone has used one of these virtual
reality devices like the oculus rift
knows there's something called the
screen door effect it's like you can see
if you look closely enough you can see
the pixels so it's not it's not a
perfect it's not a perfect simulation so
I guess really what what Zaria is doing
you say well we could get empirical
evidence for a screen door effect in
real in real physics I think it's
actually a deeper question than that
it's not about not having enough data to
resolve those distances that to some
extent that's true but the problems are
something that even bothered fine and a
lot that why do you need infinite
numbers of degrees of freedom or
infinite amount of information to
describe a very tiny chunk of a
space-time that just doesn't make sense
you can pretty well describe the physics
without actually needing that infinite
amount of what I meant to add is that
when we're zoomed down to Mars it's not
only we don't have the data even if we
did have the data you would need that
much bigger disk space to have it ready
and loaded to be able to go from a
bird's eye view down to any kind of
small I mean we rapidly run out of
capacity to calculate and that's a great
controversy that even mathematicians
have been really arguing passionately
about for over a hundred years like
Gauss one of the greatest mathematicians
ever said you know the Kronecker
actually said that he had all God
created the integers and everything else
is just the work of man and all these
continuous I mean frankly is a physicist
it feels kind of hubris thick that even
though that you know to say that you
need an infinite amount of information
to figure out the height of my wine
glass or anything nature seems perfectly
just water in there yeah what to do and
and yet what we have this toy model but
you need an infinite amount of
information to do things I think you're
you're onto something very deep this
aura and that nature actually the
infinity is just something we made up
for convenience and as we dig deeper
we're gonna find that maybe even space
and time itself comes in is it some
level digital
so can I just say something by way of
clarification which is just in physics
we don't actually prove any theory but
you can rule out theories so you can
rule out a lot of alternative theories
but in any case you can always have a
possibility that you can dig deeper and
find that your whatever theory you
thought was the most fundamental has
some underlying structure and so that's
why all the physics we've done works
that's why we really don't need to have
an infinite amount of information
anytime because we don't have access to
an infinite amount of information and we
can't even ask the question or tell
whether or not there's this underlying
infinite amount of information so it's
not just we can't just ask the question
whether the universe is a simulation we
can't ask if any physical theory is
absolutely correct we'll never know the
answer to that all we can know is that
we've tested it up to a certain level at
a certain level of precision over a
certain range and so these questions all
come with it and that's why I can
describe this glass of water without
knowing about atoms because I didn't
have what sintering experiment where the
effects of the atoms became manifest and
the same might be true of the universe
as a whole so we can have in the back of
our mind that may or may not be an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
but that's not what we're actually
testing on one thing though I think
there's one fantastic example where we
can tell it makes a huge difference I
think the biggest embarrassment we have
arguably in fundamental physics and
cosmology right now is this the fact
that inflation if it goes on forever
it makes this multiverse and then we
can't calculate probabilities like you
so eloquently said in the beginning that
comes exactly from the infinity
assumption the idea that you can take
your piece of space just keep stretching
it into twice the size you know forever
so it could just be a large number it
could be 10 to the 500 I mean it doesn't
really matter if we say you can
calculate probabilities as long as it
never gets infinite it's exactly
infinity that so he's cool with 10 to
the 500 is what he said which seems like
a really big like equals infinity to me
I think
but that's exactly the point